It's time for Drew's News!
The only news that kindly requests eight feet
of your city's finest sandwich.
(Ross laughing)
And here to help me chop this bad boy
is my trusty co-pilot, Rossy Ross Matthews!
Hi, hi everybody.
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
I have to say I'm a little distracted
by this humongous Philly cheese-steak.
By the way, Geno, I swear,
I'm gonna motorboat this Philly cheese-steak
like nobody's business.
I'm so excited.
First of all, we're riding the desk
from east to west all season long.
And today we're thrilled to be here
in the city of brotherly love.
Philadelphia!
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
Yes, please!
We're also here at the iconic LOVE sculpture by artist,
Robert Indiana, a leader in the pop art movement.
He first designed this as a painting in 1964
and brought the sculpture here in 1976.
But it's so much more than a sculpture.
It was his life's work.
And Robert Indiana did thousands of LOVE paintings
and felt everybody should have love.
He said he considered the word to be a one sentence poem.
I love this spot for the news desk, Ross.
Now this is a four letter word I can get behind.
Yeah, doesn't the world need just a little more love
right now?
Always!
Thank you so much.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
Well, another four letter word
I can also get behind is meat.
A huge thank you to you,
local legends at Geno's Steaks!
Geno's!
There they are right now, live and in the flesh.
They have been serving
authentic Philly cheese-steaks since 1966.
Ross, what's in a Philly cheese-steak?
Hit me!
Everything you ever want in life
is inside a Philly cheese-steak.
You've got thinly sliced rib-eye, perfectly fried onions,
and your choice of cheese, American, Provolone, or Whiz.
Now, what are you, which cheese would you choose?
Actually, I'd like to ask Geno,
what is in your Philly cheese-steak?
Because that's the one I trust.
Well, Drew, there's three types of cheeses.
We got American, Provolone, and Whiz.
We had to make you the famous one,
the Whiz right in front of you, enjoy.
Now, I think when in Philly,
you kind of just go big, right?
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
Drew, oh, look how petite your size is?
Look at that piece, Drew.
Oh my God.
Okay, this is perfection.
Geno.
This is incredible.
Incredible, Geno.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
Okay, I'm gonna keep picking.
In relationships, you keep eating,
I wanna talk about this.
Should you put your relationship, your partner,
up on a pedestal?
Well, Metro reports that pedestaling is a new,
that's hard to say, pedestaling is a new term
for an old habit.
Over-idealizing the person you're dating
or who you wanna date.
So for example, if you're saying things like,
oh, she's just too good for me
or he's out of my league.
And if you think, oh, if I could just be with that person,
my life would be perfect.
Well, that is called pedestaling.
And if you ask me, it is a red flag.
Therapists say the root of this habit
is your own insecurity.
And they say, when you pedestal people,
you tend to do it again and again and again.
Have you ever done it?
You know,
I definitely have done that.
You have?
Absolutely.
Let me put relationships in terms of football.
Anybody here love the Philadelphia Eagles?
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
Okay, so let me do a football metaphor for relationships.
I think everyone in a relationship should meet each other
at the 50 yard line.
You've gotta be equal people in this,
or it's never going to work.
So if you're with someone who you think
is completely out of your league,
then you've got some inner work to do on you.
That's what I think.
I agree.
All right, you can't come to Philly
and not think of hometown hero, Rocky,
jogging up those iconic stairs.
Right there!
Right there, in those iconic sweats.
Yes.
By the way.
I also love when he does like the meat locker.
Of course.
Well, Deadline reports that the man behind the champ,
Sylvester Stallone, has hit a new Hollywood milestone.
Sly stars in the Suicide Squad,
which hit number one at the box office, which means
Stallone has now had a number one movie
in six consecutive decades.
Wow!
That's why he's the champ.
He's made 46 films with 20 number ones like Rocky, Rambo,
Cliff Hanger, Driven, and The Expendables.
Congrats to Sly on an amazing career that just keeps going.
Absolutely, I always love Sylvester Stallone
'cause growing up my dad always called me Rocky.
Really?
Yeah, I don't know why.
Maybe I reminded him of Sylvester Stallone in a way.
You know what?
I'll put him on a pedestal any day.
I'll take that.
(upbeat music)